[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello chess fans welcome to day two of
the 2019 st. Louis norm Congress we are
far away in progress with round number
two of this round-robin event my name is
Ben Simon and I'm joined by Grandmaster
in residence Alexander Linderman Alex
today is gonna be a fun day we're gonna
see this round come to a conclusion
yeah I'm looking forward to it I'm
really seeing some very interesting
games and you know some very interesting
positions so I can go either way
today before we get to that let's take a
look at our standings after one round
has been played in our GM norm section
now we had all decisive games with all
three grandmasters in this division
being victorious including Andrew Hong
and Joel bonala who actually are playing
each other today those are two hopefuls
here in this norm event both players
have not achieved the Grandmaster norm
as of yet hey at the end of this thing
maybe they'll get there first let's take
a look at our standings in our
international master norms section we
had a couple of drawers here Gouri
Shankar Keaton Kira at the top I want to
issue a correction from yesterday
Justin Wang is actually an international
master in the first field I had to
mention that sorry about that but
anything is up for grabs here in the I
am norm field but if you're just joining
us for the first time and you didn't see
our pre-show yesterday you might be
asking yourself what exactly is a norm
well a norm is one of three notches that
you have to earn one of three
performances that you need to score in
tournaments where there are at least
three other players that already have
that title you have to prove yourself
worthy in this event six and a half
points is the magic number to get a norm
with just a few except exceptions but we
have many different Federation's
represented in the fields six in the
Grandmaster Norma vent five in the eye
gnorm field as well our tournament
format we have 210 player around Robbins
the time control is 90 minutes with a
30-second increment and we are getting
down to the nitty-gritty here at the end
of round number two our tournament
schedule is as follows we're gonna be
playing two rounds most days Friday
Saturday and Sunday and then we have the
two final rounds being played on Monday
and Tuesday just to give the players
enough time to warm up and get into the
home stretch and playoffs will be played
in the event of a tie for first we
encourage you to follow along on YouTube
in our chat and hashtag norm congress on
twitter to start Yavuz says oh I'm so
excited about this thanks for watching
you booze let's get into our pairings
for our GM norm section and see what
exactly is relevant here Cassie casa
Corley vs. tots of Abraham Ian JJ a
lemur on D vs. Justin Wang Brandon
Jacobson vs. Brian Escalante Danish
boroughs versus jacked and buuck have to
mention before we get to our last one
that three of these games have already
ended we know that Brandon Jacobson has
defeated Bryan Escalante as well Baros
nebuli AK and Alomar and a Wang have
come to a draw but our key matchup today
for our GM norm section andrew hong vs.
joel bonala and it's got to be the key
matchup because these two won last night
and they were the only IMS to do so it's
I actually I am Joel Piniella and they
are fighting for their first norms in
this event Alex let's take a glance at
this game so far in progress and see
where we are yeah though this is this
has been a very sharp game and very much
up and down so this was a you know
French defense classical French which
turned into my kitchen French which
leads to a very wild position our Mamoon
when I was a young kid and the master
played it against me I was 1800 I had no
idea what it was and
and then I learned and I realize it's
actually it's a very sharp line which
leads to attacking positions and I
remember I used to play this line as
white as a kid you know where you we can
you know it layered your structure on
the queenside but in return you're
playing the smoke queen g4 where you're
putting pressure on the g6 G seventh one
and now black has two moves as far as I
know g6 which is also a mainline after
Bishop d3 and the move that was played
in a game king of faith which I think
leads to more sharp position and I
haven't really kept up with the
modern-day theory on this but all I know
is it leads to very sharp positions
where white tries to get an attack and
black tries to either get a Queen side
attack or maybe try to play an endgame
where he has a slightly better one
structure so specialty three Knight 62
King takes T to c5 and I would probably
be more inclined to try it for rogue h3
going for attacks but this was very
sharp and yeah I'm not sure exactly who
this favors but it looks like black
should already be doing quite okay
because he has counter play here on any
five c5 triple pawns you don't see that
too often
yeah actually in this line it's happened
quite a few times for me especially when
they Cal so long and the g6 lines but
okay that's the different stories Knight
of three Queen c7 he doesn't rush taking
the point he can take the pawns on e5 or
c5 any time Queen a for Knight 65 h4 and
now white starts his attack with rook h3
roof g3 Bishop g7 rook h3 rook c8 so
black is already threatening some things
like Knight 63 and Queen sexy three
winning the ropes so white has to act
accordingly and he does so with a move
94 good idea of meeting this with rook
takes d3 and the rook conveniently is
not only looking at attacking but also
defending the Kiwi
so black played Bishop I ate maybe it
was all so deserving attention to get
the King out of the way right away with
King g8 but this ship I ate was played
to Russia 3 and now black plate of 5
again I'm not sure if that was strictly
necessary there was maybe other moves as
well like Knight 63 with the idea of
gaining a tempo with rook takes d3 or if
white goes very ambitious with Knight
takes c6 it actually backfires because
of King is 7 and suddenly no matter what
you do you're gonna lose a piece in this
position for example here here or if
rook takes d 3f takes c6 so black so
that was possible but he played a 5
after a 5 isn't he losing a pawn if just
a takes c6 of 6 Queen takes of four was
disappoint oh of course
so couldn't quite do that but rook rook
e1 King g8 and still I think black is
having a good position rookie 3 and the
queen of 7 I'm not sure about this move
maybe it was better to go Bush page 5
and not have the Queen blocked at Bishop
so maybe that was a little bit better
but queen of 7 was played King he won
the shove d7 location 3 and now this
should be 2 may be preparing for g4
sometimes and now maybe it wasn't better
to try this but you play Knight of 3
this should be 8 king of 1 and here we
are in in this position where it's
blacks move or is it actually this
position or maybe something has changed
since so let's yeah just click on it
this one y on the left yeah this one oh
yeah yeah wait
sorry hongbin hour right there it's it's
highlighted right there yeah okay go so
there were some move more moves made
Queenie 7 g 4 takes takes Queen of 7 and
Queen G 2 and still it's a very unclear
game it's anyone's game
a White has potential attacks but so
does Black has pressure on the F file
you know it's it's just one of these
position that's very hard to evaluate
both sides has its pluses and it's one
of these positions where one mistake can
be very costly this is the game to watch
it this is gonna be the game that goes
really down to the wire
I think I feel and also notice how White
has four minutes and Black has 15
minutes so time will definitely probably
be a factor here where you know very
easily you know time pressure mistake
can really cost you the game no doubt no
doubt we'll get back to this game in
just a bit but let's pop over to our IM
norm division our group B Keaton Kira
vs. Aaron Jacobson Rochelle Wu versus
Eric Rosen Luis Torres versus Erin
Griffin ski Ezra chambers versus Peter
Gian ADO's we have one game that has
finished Luis Torres versus Erin Griffin
ski that was a win for Torres but our
key matchup in this division has to be
Vijay master at Gauri Shankar taking on
Kenta chiku rate' we called him Olivier
yesterday he said I don't want to go by
Kenta
so we'll call him Kenta let's glance at
this game and see where we are we will
scroll down here to Oh
so let's find that game okay so here we
are yeah
so this just the way it looks it looks
very very interesting so let's see how
it played out so this was a Dutch
defense already very ambitious
double-edged opening as we might know as
we might remember he Carly Kimura one
decisive game at the recent US
Championship with the Dodge against
Jeffrey stone and that was a beautiful
game if you're a fan of the Dutch
defense I highly recommend you take a
look at that game and hear a white went
form a slightly not off beat setup it's
actually very popular
as well but kind of went a little bit
under the radar because more common
these days is set up so at night of
three castles and then let's say C 4 B 3
and so on but in this game he played a
more sharp system with night of a night
H 3 night of 4 and H 4 going for an
attack and in this line black has to you
know be very precise as far as I
remember the main line is supposed to be
knight c6 trying to play for some e5 you
know not canceling too quickly here
because as we can see here he Castle
very quickly and so they attack and
maybe that was a little bit dangerous
Queen e8 h v g5 and now white came up
with a very good move h6 because if he
moved the knight back
Blackwell h6 and suddenly black would
stabilize the whole situation but he
included there very nice Intermezzo h6
where black has to go back because if he
was gonna take that
then after takes takes takes blacks
kinks that would be completely in ruins
and white has too many threats to handle
so he went back but now the g5 plan
becomes significantly week and it was
possibly better to go Knight g3 that way
after g4 you can just develop instead he
played Knight h3 got your shon-kar and
at least I gave black a temple to try to
regroup himself but still of course that
4 and h6 is a very unpleasant thing for
black to deal with it's like a lot of
clouds gathering around this King and at
any moment blacks position here could
collapse for now his position is sort of
together but it's certainly white one
the opening battle here and now white
went for c4 Knight c3 a very logical
plan c6 and 93 it was also may be
possible to go right away free for but
white played this is not a mistake takes
takes e4 26 Queen d2 going and on the g5
square nearing the king
rooty 895 yeah and this move I'm not
sure if that was the best move because
here just gets attacked and maybe loses
a temple so maybe it was better to start
with a move like b3 just getting that
last piece in the game somehow but you
went 95 Queen e7 Queen g5 king of seven
and now he ended up going back to b3 but
I kind of doubt that that was the best
plan because now I feel like the knight
on v3 is also a little bit misplaced
Knight a six black completes his
development it was also possible to try
this attacking this and try and
developing this way but it's a very
complicated position so it's very hard
to criticize the players here
castles night before EF Ruby g8 Queen h4
Knight see to rugby 194 so now we see
that black four group tonight so good
square where it maybe three things about
taking on a5 white played rook e1 eyeing
on this porn trying to get the rook in
the game Knight takes B 3 so if 96 of 5
I'm wondering if white really wanted to
go Queen h1 or with you know some
pressure here but I still feel like that
should have been played and after room
g6 black is probably close to fine but
he took and b3 trading off a good night
for this night and b3 which is a little
bit restricted and now he token of 5 and
let's see if this was so there were a
couple of more moves ok one Queen e6
Bishop e3 and I think in this position
white is still slightly better
I mean blacks King is still in a long
run weaker than whites white has
relatively active pieces and you know
right now also they 7th ones hanging and
the 4 point could be a factor for white
it's potentially an outpost and even
though black is still kind of defending
but it's a tough position for black to
play and also notice how he's now only
living off of the increment so this will
be a struggle for
going forward but of course it's a
complicated position anything can still
happen all right very nice thank you
very much we do have breaking news in
Group B two players who are fighting for
their first IM norms have ended the game
and it was the head of the charlet chess
centre VJ Master Peter Jian otto's who
was victorious over Ezra chambers
bringing both players to an equal score
before we take a look at that game and
hopefully we get to talk to Peter down
here in just a few moments let's take a
look at the prize fund we have people in
the chat wondering what is the prize for
this event well ultimately for most of
them it's a norm but for everyone we
have some money nine thousand dollars
total on the line with two grand going
to the champion of our top group and in
our second group we have a six thousand
dollar prize fund that the winner will
walk away with twelve hundred dollars
and all the players are guaranteed to
not lose money by coming here to st.
Louis this is gonna this is a great
event the hospitality is always great
here in st. Louis especially for an
event like the norm Congress this is
where we make the superstars of the game
tomorrow now let's go around the horn
Alex and take a look at this game that
just ended between Ezra and Peter yeah
that's what I'm trying to do now and it
looks like black played a little bit of
an offbeat opening as we saw in the
Bonneville game you know their night of
six was played and that's sort of a main
line one of the main lines besides the
win over and what things Peter is here
right now so I'm going to take take
leave and he'll be here and just above
it sounds good
so as we could see in this game Peter
played the move knight c6 it's a
slightly offbeat line but also very much
playable and here there's several ways
white can play I think a popular way to
play I think is Bishop d3 with the idea
of just protecting everything where you
cannot take because of takes takes and
Bishop e5
in that case maybe a block can go night
before and then castles and you know you
can get a game like this but we have the
move Bishop c5 plate and then after this
it looks like block already got a
comfortable game because because black
has counter play with c5 and so on and
and here we have Peter in the studio
with us so talk about the game yell
Peter how do you feel about the game
well I I lost a pretty passive on
position yesterday where basically I was
I was white but I was like I was playing
black and so I wanted to play a little
bit offbeat opening today to see if I
could catch my opponent a little bit
unaware and and to try to win with to
try to try to get back to 50% so yeah so
I played this Knight c96 on move three
in the French and I wasn't I wasn't
quite sure like how how it all went like
I'm on move 12 B 6 mm-hmm I mean I guess
I could trade on I guess I could trade
on b3 but I thought after b6 there's
just more more complicated more
double-edged yes it goes up tonight 6 b3
you know you can do this yeah I thought
takes takes Queen Queen before something
like wait before Queen g4 and the black
is certainly comfortable but it could be
a bit draw yes certainly you know it's a
very logical decision b6 to have a more
unbalanced structure than to keep more
waiting chances on the board yeah I
think I sort of thought if if like he
pretty much has to take because the
knight own b3 doesn't make a lot what if
he takes details if I thought I thought
he
I guess I have to take 90hp 396 b3 and
then yeah you know you can probably take
with either porn it takes years
Queen takes Queen takes is possible yeah
I actually looked at this yeah 484 yes
still looks equal issues but yes yes are
they fighting yeah yeah III thought he
would you know he would definitely
thought I sort of thought it might go be
six and I take say five and he played c4
because I mean otherwise I was gonna go
see for him but I 4c for Bishop a4 queen
a3 exactly start pressuring on the
weaknesses yeah and I thought if I push
his Bishop back off of that diagonal
it's it's all black there yes so c4 is
very logical exactly and here here I was
you know I felt I felt a little bit
nervous because I hadn't castled yet and
I wanted to go pawn c4 that take takes
on c4 which is what I did and then here
Bishop c6 is after takes Bishop C
instead of it's not the castle but then
I thought d5 mm-hm
and originally I thought rody Luke d8
but then I started thinking he could
probably take the bishop
yes act the Queen and I have nothing to
attack and that pawn is alive yeah
you're right this is actually completely
lost for you because she's coming 57 and
you know also Bishop potentially
controls the Queen Square
yeah this is very dangerous and in fact
the engine says you're completely losing
here I'm glad I had good judgement there
yeah that was a very good judgement so I
Castle I castle mm-hmm and I almost
thought a hundred percent he was gonna
go d5 here I don't know why I mean I I
because my pawn on c5 looks like a Miss
there I thought it would take and then
go rook d8 Bishop takes rook e8 yes and
you're completely fine here but of
course this would be much harder to win
I was already sort of resigning myself
to a draw like okay I'll go I'll help
move got Queen e2 or something I'll go
Bishop e6 and that'll be the end of that
yeah well I think any positions
potentially winner Bob of course
realistically speaking most likely
result as a draw here yeah but you know
that's yes sometimes that happens you
know even in my experience is playing in
the US Championship sometimes it happens
you're resigned to a draw get a certain
result you know the game's kind of going
boring and suddenly you get a little
chance here yeah it's important when you
do get a chance to take max
advantage of that chest yeah I was very
surprised he played rugby one and then
allowing me to go Bishop c6 I was very
happy here because some of you want to
play anyway he wanting to go for the
cheap threat rugby 7 but of course you
want to go Bishop c6 anyways so wasn't
loud yeah so and and here just little by
little he was just yeah I think here
when he after Bishop b5 I think he just
missed that after Bishop d5 c4 I have
bishop before I think he missed that in
his brain possibly even this would have
been playable probably would be 2 and
then rook e1 but of course yeah Rock da
theater of did - yes not so bad exactly
exactly I think he was sort of alarmed
that I had I think that's what he
intended to play original and then he
played rugby - which i think is just is
just yeah real good - is definitely
that's sake and now here no so after
Ruby b8 I think here I couldn't decide
he played by the way one moment did you
consider starting with Queen b7 I didn't
know yeah okay I'm attacking g2 and I'm
threatening a6 yeah yeah I'm not sure
how good that is maybe I'm because he
still has options like Queen a1 Bishop
takes Jitsu
rook e1 but of course it's a move that
it's good to look at because of similar
throw b8 yeah and it's a move that could
actually win the game potentially yeah
things yeah completely I completely
missed I was just I almost thought after
rook b8 I just didn't know what he was
gonna do I was like what what a weird
and then he played Queen d2 I was like
okay and then I hear I don't know if I
did the right thing because of course I
can win a pawn here but I was really
intrigued by the pup you know that that
his bishop was so out of the game I
played c4 but I don't know how good that
is
it's very logical I was playing against
the bishop on b5 and they didn't want
him to go see four because I mean the
whole point is if I if I go a six he
goes c4 and I can win a pawn there but I
didn't think that was the best I could
do I it's probably good for black but I
I really like thought I could make more
of the position yeah that makes a lot of
sense no this this was a very
interesting decision giving up material
maybe but also getting all that Queen g5
into fire
because once I take on d4 like if he
goes g3 I agree I think yes I'm a six
takes you 24 yeah I was I thought I was
yeah I thought of going Queen G for
first and then just taking on d4 cuz my
pawn is for first yeah then maybe Quincy
three okay he just comes back maybe
that's good to go a6 but in any event
that's pretty clear that it's very good
for you and then you can figure out what
the best time yeah I wasn't concerned
about that and yeah and then so I'm glad
I'm glad the computer says c4 is okay
because it took me a while to actually
hit upon that actual at first it doesn't
like it but then once you play that
likes it much more so that even actually
says how good the idea is because it's
like one of these hidden ideas that's
underestimated at first right that's a
very good idea thank you rugby one and
now maybe Quinn a3 finishes off even
easier yes I thought g3 here this should
be four Oh after I just completely
missed that after C 3 I have Bishop
before hitting the road yeah okay but of
course you know when you already have
such a good option yeah rugby six it's
you know hard to force yourself plus you
know and win this time control without a
second time control you don't really
want to get into time to shoot I just in
all that he didn't play Bishop a4 yeah
he should tried I mean good or bad it's
it looks losing but at least it's still
here him in a game yeah I mean I thought
was the only way only wait for yeah and
I was like I don't know I mean I'm you
know I'm happy but I'm not winning like
I'm not it's not clear exactly how I'm
gonna win yet yeah exactly but yeah he
probably blunders I think it's just it's
just over yeah it's totally yeah so I
thought here yeah so h6 Queen h4 I mean
he's trying to trick me I even thought
of going a6 and just Bishop takes rook
takes b2 taking all the material and
then picking up the bishop probably with
rook on eight yeah and and I thought
that was pretty powerful yeah but I just
played King h7 threatening a6 so that
there's no trick because basically he's
going for Bishop a6 and queen dhx oh and
if it goes Queen you won you go away six
anywhere right yeah that's what I did
yeah yeah so I think you're winning in
many different ways
yeah you have to just choose the
simplest one yeah so yeah and then yeah
the rest is of course man this relative
you know important no I think the rest
is relatively simple
yeah Quincy v g6 h3 ya know it was a
very good game so thank you good job
very nice to recover all from previous
games I think the opening choice worked
out very well it's clear that you
understood the position quite well and
you saw a lot of the things so it looks
like you're getting back into form and
yeah wish you best of luck in the next
few hours thank you thank you for having
me no problem
so let's now go back to the game between
garish on car and Oliver chick-chick
arathi Kenta and see what happened here
and while we were speaking with Peter so
last time we were you know we were at
this position and we were saying how
white was bit better so since then black
decided to sacrifice the sport maybe it
was better to still play a six
you know defending but he decided to
give up the poor and white happily took
it black went for counterblow woody for
white played the Queen h1 idea as we
discussed before putting pressure on 94
maybe it was better more practical to
just go Bishop g4 and neutralize this
diagonal and getting the bishop off of
a7 but he went Queen h1 rook here Bishop
t4 takes takes and Queen g6 but there
was a very interesting option maybe
since he already sacrificed one point
maybe it deserved attention to sacrifice
another one and try some nice five and
some crazy counter play but you played
Queen d6 and now we're at this position
and the rook t1 was just played alive
and again we can still see that white is
very much in the driver's seat but of
course with this time control and with
the time station still anything can
absolutely happen well Alex I gotta say
while we were talking to Peter big
developments in the tournament first of
all it's a great day for the Jacobson
brothers because Aaron has just won his
game again
Keaton Kira in Group B the I am division
we can glance at that in a moment but i
think i think hong versus bonala is is
having some interesting development yeah
so let's take a look at that let's go
there first and and maybe we'll get
Aaron in here for an interview
yes so let's see hung against the banaba
yes so it definitely had a lot of
interesting moments and let's see what
happens so we were all around here so
you know ever since it looks like oh
yeah even here there was so what
happened here Queen of five maybe that
wasn't the best move actually because
that's simply allowed a temple on that
Queen you know because now this is a
threat and then next move coming is 94
so this move Queen of five definitely
looks like a mistake losing to Tempest
and now white is already very much in
control
maybe Bishop d3 was also deserving
attention trying to trade off night for
for Bishop and leaving himself with a
very good night against the bad bishop
on he ate what she played mister g4
Queen e7 rogue f3 Bishop d7 Queen h3
yeah maybe it was good to a trade of
this rook because one thing that I teach
all my students is that when opponent
has a bad piece or special a couple of
long-term bad pieces it's often good
good idea to trade off the neutral
pieces and that way is gonna be much
harder for opponent to play with there
they're kind of stuck with the bad
pieces it's like a general principle but
now after this I rotate shape
King you won it's not as clear because
the king is now escaping and suddenly
this rook which was just bad he was able
to activate it and now again Black is
fine rook g3 rook f7 rulesheets Uruk f8
and now suddenly the black who's doing
very well this should be to look at for
maybe King h8 was good here just getting
out of all the checks and for example
this would you know be much less so
factor later on Raqqa for Queen x2
and here maybe it was made sense to do
this and threaten this he went there
King h8 rope here look for of seven and
this looks like it was a actually a
tactical blunder because white action
had a chance to do rook takes g7 and
after rook takes g7 he would take
followed by a taking on f4 and if rook
takes f2 then you can go rook e8 King h7
and maybe even a move like 93 and you
know black loose lost the key points so
most likely he just overlooked rook
takes f7 whereas if he just goes here
threatening 94 and maybe Queen a3 black
looks like he's completely still in
control so this was a probably tactical
oversight but white she had you know
they're both playing close to an
increment white missed this opportunity
and black then played the move Queen h4
and now it's black who probably is again
a bit better reminder these players have
30 second increments so every move 30
seconds is added on but still it's not
very comfortable to play with just 1
minute left on your clock as we see both
the players there by the window so it
looks like Queen g1 was played getting
out of the Queen trade and also
potentially threatening on yourself and
not right away because of the pin but
maybe after the King moves alright let's
take a look at the other game that's
still going on in our Grandmaster
Division Casa Corley versus tattoo of
Abraham Ian yeah and in this position
looks like there are a lot of things
have happened since we last looked last
time we looked we looked somewhere
around this moment where we're basically
white had a slight but stable edge had
control over the c6 square and was just
pressing but then a few developments
came and now white is the one they
repeated moves a couple of times
probably to get some time on the clock
and you know white is still pressing he
decided to secure the knight on c6 here
and now he decided to reposition the
Knight to d5 and maybe go with the rook
to c6
so repositioning of the pieces and
eventually black ended up winning the b5
point but at a very high cost white was
able to win the f6 pawn and now the King
is becoming a factor as well as a lot of
the King side points so white gave up a
one advantage for another but here it
looks like Brooke e6 was maybe a bit
more accurate but he played there and
now he 4 was played here black missed a
very good chance to get very good
counter play King g7 rook takes here and
b5 and suddenly White's pieces are
losing a bit of coordination and black's
pawn is actually going very fast with
the rook behind the poor but black in
this position played efore and here now
it was White's turn to miss the very
nice opportunity he could have gone room
d8 check King g7 room g8 and if black
ignores the threat widest threatening
takes takes and here and the rule is
usually when three pieces attack the
King an open King it usually leads to
very bad things and actually black
cannot defend the position here but
white played another tempting move
Knight of four what does you know let go
of some part of the advantage so now
white found a cute tactic winning the
pawn on e4 with the idea of having this
fork and now we have a position where
white is up a pawn and now notice how I
decided to offer a night raid hoping for
rook endgame and this certainly would
have given maybe blacks some drawing
chances but black decided to go Knight
g4 and after route d2 we have now this
position now there are a couple of moves
made since I'd be three knight c6 roca
for
kingi 595 Roque 793 king g6 and what can
we say about this position
why does our perform but it's a more
dynamic kind of opponent game where
black has counter play always with the
b-pawn but white has also foreign to on
the Kings side so white has a good
chance of making at some point connected
passers on the Kings side so this is
gonna be down to the wire this could end
up being a race and this couldn't be
still anyone's game
of course white is favorite right now
but I wouldn't even be surprised if
somehow black swindles the win
Coralie representing Denmark comes to us
from New York City he has one Grand
Master norm so he's playing for a second
tatev has just about a million I am norm
she's just trying to cross the 2400
threshold and she's she could earn a GM
norm here as well up against the odds so
let's jump over to the IM section
rochelle woo versus Eric Rosen Eric we
know him very well around here former
commentator here at this desk as well
and a very notable streamer and Rochelle
whoo looks to be in the driver's seat am
i right to say that yes Rochelle who is
definitely better she's up a poor black
doesn't have very much counter play
compensation on item d2 controls all the
key squares most notably their b1 square
and also black scheme is a bit weak so
it's safe to say that why definitely has
a big advantage but of course again
there's time situation where Rochelle
only has she's playing an increment and
of course Eric also doesn't have tons of
time so last time I saw this game it was
some around here there's a very
complicated game so we won't be able to
go over all the critical moments right
now but after a lot of dust has settled
while white here found a very nice
tactic to kind of for to conceive v with
the idea being after this there's rookie
seven and no good defense from the mate
threat
so Rochelle was very sharp with her
tactics here so black played Bishop e8
which is a good defensive move 90 for
this for g6 b3 of course here black can
recover the porn and probably the engine
will
kind of equal ish but black at this
point probably was hoping for more be
three rooks cd8 king b2 and now Eric
decided to go for f3 which again if he
wants to play an equal at games you can
take and take here but Eric probably
wants to play a bit more ambitiously but
this kind of backfires because now if
white just goes root D to do these six
bonus covered and looks like this f3
thing is not going anywhere
so Queen f3 Ruby six rookie 2 rookies
692 and now White's sort of
consolidating her position and and now
this is where we are where white is kind
of in control and there have been a
couple of more moves made but they don't
impact the game that much and in fact
now white is up two pawns and if white
plays move like a five you know white
will be in the driver's seat here well
nicely done so far by Richelle who's out
rated by about a 150 feet at classical
points by rosin Rochelle doesn't have
any I am Norma's but she does have one
wgm norm and with six points in this
field she'll get both and I am and a wgm
knotch
so we'll check back on this in a second
but how about our key matchup in Group B
Gauri Shankar versus Kenta Ishii karate
yeah so there's been a lot of
developments recently so last time we
left off somewhere around here and then
ever since you know there are a couple
or more moves so white like King edge to
Queen e6 Queen e1 it's consolidating and
proving the Queen so maybe III square
rocky eight Queen III Queen a5 King G 1
so this was a good maneuver you know now
the King you know it's a very is very
safe and also protects f2 so blacks
getting short on counter play and now
white is the one taking control over
that open a file and suddenly it's white
the one with the extra point and the
compensation so Knight a for rookie 796
Queen c7 or okay
and now white is basically completely in
control completely winning and guyue is
a player who oftentimes gets into time
pressure so actually two minutes is
quite a lot of time for him with
increments so I think he has a very good
chance of converting this position where
the next report and very good position a
couple moves just played really quick
there on the board
oh yes so rook a 8 so black traded rooks
there was really nothing else and now
you know it's probably a good idea to
play c5 before and securing this night
on b6 and maybe freeing the bishop on c4
and the Queen on e3 for more useful
roles and also c5 can be potentially
prepared you know can potentially be a
prelude to Knight see 496 as well
twenty-six-year-old that Gauri Shankar
has all of his norms actually he's just
trying to get his rating at to 2400 that
threshold where he can be awarded as an
IM elect he's at 23 75 we'll see where
he lands after this tournament is over
as far as Kenta he has to I am norms
he's going for his third in this event
okay the let's check back in with
Hongbin awah key matchup in Group A yes
so let's go back there Hongbin Nava Oh a
lot of things have changed oh now black
has looks like he's very much in control
I see a pawn on c3 I mean look enough
three Queens about to come to a three so
let's see what happened when we left off
black was doing well but it looks like
his position has improved some more
because now black is looking at the
weakness on c3 and White's pieces are
pushed back there should be three before
a very nice idea opening up the game and
now white play 92 which didn't seem like
was a very good move it was probably
better to go here and after this just to
hide the King somehow but do you know
again and that's in the position like
this is very hard to play you know the
best move so he played 92 driving the
night away from a good square and now
black took this pawn which is also very
important pawn
and now white is kind of scuffling with
some rookie forint it looks like you
know whites fighting on his last legs in
this game is there anything even to
fight for for white here looks like he's
purely on the defensive um well I mean
it's let's see there's what's the
material one two three four one two
three four five six so White's down two
pawns but of course there's I mean it's
still a position where you can blunder
right that's still you know there's
still pieces on the board and black
still has to prove that she finds the
winning plan so it's certainly a lost
position for white but not hopeless in a
practical game right obviously black is
a very big favor to Windows at this
point but I mean when you're in time
pressure anything can still happen so
and there is still some moves made
ninety five and the ship g6 so you know
as far as I know when you're defending
positions like that the main thing I try
to you know do when I'm trying to defend
a position like that is so at least not
lose right away try to you know find a
move before you resign you know as long
as you can and then you never know
I mean maybe your opponent won't play
the best winning plan and you can little
by little get back in the game that's
usually my approach when I try to defend
at least try not to make it easy for
them try to hold on as long as he can
but so far bonobos doing just fine he
activated this Bishop you know now his
Bishop which earlier was a bad piece now
it's really impacting the game he wants
to trade it all for them Knight and
there's really nothing white can do
because if he moves the knight to d4
then there's rook F once so at this
point yet looks not good for white but
of course anything can always still
happen Alex let's jump over to Group B
it looks like Eric Rosen might be might
be about to resign against Rochelle woo
hmm wow so Rochelle just played a very
interesting move g5 with the idea of if
takes route e7i and opening up the file
yeah well resign might be a little
quickly said but of course yeah white is
definitely completely winning and
white really hasn't messed this up well
c5 it was a very practical move with
idea after this to go into a relatively
safe endgame it might not be the best
solution because that endgame might be
hard to win but anyway Eric Rosen should
have tried to do that but Eric decided
to keep Queens on the board but I just
don't agree with that decision because I
don't necessarily think that White's
King is weaker than blacks the knight
and e2 is a very good defensive piece
whereas blacks King is still under very
much fire so I don't really agree with
the decision of trying to keep Queens on
the board for Eric and now well actually
this hasn't happened yet but basically
after g5 via black isn't quite a lot of
trouble and they're they're definitely a
very good chance for shell wins this
game well not all hope is lost for Eric
as you said most of it though Ragnarok
56 in our chat says let's go Eric so he
has at least one fan I know he has a
whole bunch more and remember if you
guys are just watching this on youtube
be sure to jump on over to us chess
champs calm we have four games left and
you can check them at your whimsy and
there's some breaking news in the guy or
car game and amazingly enough black is
actually now not worse in an endgame so
it looks like guy you were actually
really badly miss played this so in this
position this is where we left off why
it was completely winning and we were
saying stuff like c5 before Knight c4
just little by little improving the
position black really has nothing
productive he can do but instead guy you
were decided to force action Bishop
takes of six bad practical decision
trading off his excellent Bishop on g4
which just controls everything for the
pinned knight on f6 which he can take
almost at any moment just to grab this
pawn on e4 and suddenly black has life
because this bishop now is a very active
piece suddenly c5 he played it now Queen
e5 and in this position white missed a
great opportunity to finish off the game
with a very nice tactic Knight c4
meeting Queen takes d4 with 96 check
winning the game and otherwise going 96
we're white is just up to clear pawns
without any counter play whatsoever but
instead he took on g6 right away and
this was a huge mistake it lets go of a
lion's share of the advantage and after
this he had traded the Queen's and went
into this ending but this engine endgame
was gonna be very hard if even possible
to win because white will only be up a
pawn and also notice how all these bones
are on dark squares and black causes our
tradition which is now very good so this
is going to be very very hard to win so
why tried before but objectively
speaking this is actually probably
closer to a draw then to a win I often
hear when you are in the lead don't
trade off your pieces under any
circumstances don't let things be
consolidated because there goes your
attack and it okay here we have joel
bana wa and Andrew Hong has come to an
end in Group A and it looks like banana
with the bow I wanted to add that if
you're up let's say a piece or a rope
then of course trading off simply is
very easy but if you're only up a pawn
now sometimes it's not enough to just
blindly go ahead and start trading or
race so porn is not quite enough where
you shot you have to just say okay I'll
trade everything Morphin simple enough
all right so let's check how what
happened in the banaba game and it looks
like Eric Andrew Hong indeed lost on
Bonneville and did once so let's see the
finish of the game this should be 593
Queen f8 so 93 definite wasn't helpful
either quinna fate kingi 197 a very nice
backward move attacking that last one
weakness and because of White's
misplaced pieces
he couldn't even really defend it and
here banaue a finished with a flourish
tactic 965 Queen 65 rook F 1 check
Knight takes of 1 is almost forced and
then just Queen decks f1 Queen e1 and
the should be 2 and in the game he
played Queen e1 right away and still
Queen f3 and he resigned so wonderful
finish by Joel Bonneville very clutch
moves at the right time at some point he
had a tough defense notice lay earlier
he had a moment where he played
you know some queen of five fruits III
and he had to go back queen of seven he
lost to tempies and sometimes when you
make a mistake like that it's very
unpleasant so play after that knowing
you've just you know kind of miss played
the position but Joel fought like a lion
this game once he got a tough position
and took over the game later on so and
now we know that Joel is in first place
right now and he's going to be in clear
first at the end of this round and we do
have an evening round later on tonight
that starts at 5 p.m. Central time but
great start here for Joel bana WA
hopefully we can get him in the studio
one of the most well-spoken guys I know
in the game ok with one game left going
in a the the corley game shall we
glance back at Group B Alex oh sure
and let's check again on a Rochelle
Woo's game against Eric Rosen and see if
there are any interesting developments
that happened so last time we looked g5
was played black you know took on the
challenge took upon I mean what else can
Eric - Rock d7 Bishop f7 only moved to
stop the mate Queen of 6 good move rook
f8 only move again Queen takes g5 King
h8 I mean maybe Bishop g6 was a little
bit more resilient but it's still
probably losing King h8 25 and now 90
for the night you know for a long time
was a very good defensive piece but as
you could see very quickly Knights are
jumpy pieces right and very quickly it
can actually be a very good attacking
piece and notice how with the bishop
coming here there's no more need to
control the b1 square and if black goes
Queen g2 just ripped it soo
so black black tried Quinn Jitsu indeed
rogue d2 and Queen g7 so at this point
black has no choice but to trade Queen's
otherwise he gets made it but of course
here white is totally winning in the
position I do want to mention that King
see 3 might have been even more accurate
because then after Queen g7 takes takes
96 this is just game over trading into
winning King and pawn endgame and if you
try to do Quint xh3 years some sorts
then route III and there's
even Queen she's seven but okay the way
Rachelle played is also should be
completely winning with takes on Ruby
seven or even night of six and we'll see
what way Rachelle will try to win this
okay and how about our key matchup in be
gory Schenker and she carotid oh you're
a chunk car yes so this end game kind of
went us as expected you know basically a
few pawns got traded on the Queen side
so I tried to play B three in order to
go ninety six but black decided to go
here Knight a5 here maybe there was one
last chance to try b5 and ninety-six
maybe that was a slightly better chance
but most likely it still leads to a draw
after King g7 and then if Knight 6b 7
then King of six King comes close enough
but he tried Knight a5 takes takes King
G 698 takes takes and unfortunately this
will be probably hard to win in probably
impossible because the vegetable park
here on b6 and how is white ever gonna
make progress
pardon me Alex I do have word that we do
have Joel bonamo ready for an interview
so I will be back in just a bit
sounds good so let's see
once again the job ANOVA game and and
let's go over some critical moments in
this game so let's go right to the
critical moment when in this position
let's go all the way to the start so
with Bishop g5 Bishop before this was
the opening and so king of takes takes
takes 97 Knight of three Queen c7 and h4
Bishop d7 rogue h3 Roxy 894 Bishop I ate
and
and let's start right here
so welcome Joel congratulations on a
very nice fighting win how do you feel
about this game it's unbelievable I'm
still I don't know I'm still stressing
it was a really stressful game there's a
lot of tactics it was to watch it to
stuff right right yeah what are you
first of all what do you think were the
main critical moments in this game what
do you think was the first part of the
moment for you or your opponent I think
when it was when I had to play Bishop 8
after 94 after 94 originally of course
blacks main idea is to play Knight a4
but there's a lot of tricks you could
just play brick f3 if so nine a4 root of
three right good and it looks like now
if you go Bishop e8 there's a c6 here
right so that's why Joel played Bishop
e8 a little bit of a prophylactic also
maybe King G first King g8 was also I
was also thinking about playing a6 first
and then I think it's gonna transpose
back to the game if you please rook e1
and then f5 yeah the lines are very
similar yes so Bishop e8 is probably a
fine move rook rook c3 and now have five
also pretty good move based on the idea
that takes Queen decks are four of
course and trying to just shut down the
attack so white played rook e1 King g8
rookie three and in this position you
played the Queen of seven yes which is
probably pretty good did you consider by
the way the move Bishop h5 here first
not really I was I was worried that he
might have some sort of like sacrifice
and f5 maybe he doesn't but it just
looks scary I feel like I need my bishop
on it just in case
mm-hmm that makes sense yeah so queen of
seven King you one Bishop d7 rogue h3
rook f8 this is all a very good defense
h5 a six
this should be to b5 maybe white could
have played c4 but yeah Mr P to be five
Knight of three Bishop eh so this was
all probably best play
Queen f7 or close to best play but if I
I was trying to rattle him on the clock
so I completely forgot 94 so you you
probably miss the well if the goes 94
right away I think oh yeah he just don't
you so let me ask you a question there
so whenever we play a move that you know
you're know right away it's it's kind of
a mistake you know losing just two
tempies right how were you able to what
were your thoughts what were your
thoughts at that moment and how were you
able to recover and play a great game
after that because I know it could be
hard obviously I was just thinking
positively I was thinking you know what
okay I messed up but my position is
still solid if somehow I can defend and
here's a lot of weak points and I could
I could just defend this as much as I
can very good approach you know so
audience definitely take note I'll
definitely take note for myself
that's when chefs will have to always
look at it positively right yeah we
can't ever have negative thoughts
whatever happens happens we have to just
accept it and just play on the rest of
the game as if nothing happened so of
course in this position white is doing
well but maybe Bishop d3 was deserving
attention trying to trade off that good
night here yes like you played Bishop g4
Queen e7 rook f3 and here he you
probably should have exchanged the rooks
because I teach everybody that when one
has some bad pieces it's good to try to
trade off the neutral ones but he for
some reason didn't do that and now you
found a good plan just activating the
rope right I didn't do anything on h7
and now it's you who is in control right
but there was one more important moment
where he had released yeah rook takes g7
yeah I saw it after after yeah yeah so
how did you feel when he didn't do that
I was relieved yeah but of course a huge
time pressure anything can happen so he
played up three and that was huge relief
of course yes Queen h4 and from this
point on you played an excellent game
Queen e7 before it was all it was you're
in control from here on
and of course 92 also doesn't help you
know because weakening that very square
I was thinking actually after
before maybe roof g6 was his idea that's
a bishop d3 I was kind of worried about
this you I guess you couldn't play queen
of eight here though right queen of
eight you know maybe it's a better trade
but still of course you know you're
still doing well but of course he should
have tried something like that right but
he played 92 and after that it was euro
completely in control and from this
point on he also didn't defend maybe in
the perfect way and you know this should
be five was very nice finally that
Bishop which was kind of a defensive
piece all game and you know plays a big
part in the attack and you know you
finished in a very nice flourish 97 was
very nice of course you know it looks
like a knife should stay somewhere here
you know attacking but you know of
course you know as I teach my students
you want to attack the key weakness
right in the position and and the final
tactic was also great so congratulations
on a great win so how do you feel going
into the next game I'm not trying to get
too confident
I'm just taking it one game at a time
and you know what happens happens sounds
good that's the great approach so I wish
you best of luck going forward and wish
you some more beautiful games like this
thank you appreciate it
alright thanks for thanks for coming all
right so let's go back to see what
happened in the Casa Coyle against at
sea of game we haven't looked at that
game for a while so let's see what what
has happened last time we left off in
some end game where it was basically
white was pressing and now white was
able to exchange a pair of pawns here
and it looks like black should have
tried rook f7 here but he took and that
seems like a very big blunder because
actually after king g6 white could have
won the game on a spot here with rook
takes e5 now I'm wondering if maybe
Castle saw this but maybe he thought
that this pawn is still gonna be
unstoppable but it turns out that after
a four if let's say King c5 because of B
3 for example 95 93 will easily stop the
porn maybe he thought King C 5 but it
turns out white
actually wins the race we 3 of 6 b2 f7
and white Queens with Czech and white
will win the game and if King d6 then
white will just go night b5 and stop
this pawn so it turns out that white
could have won like this but maybe white
thought it's not so clear and you played
a four but this actually you know let's
go over the big part of the advantage
and the white is still of course
pressing but now certainly black has you
know very good drawing chances and there
were a couple of more moves played but I
think this probably this end game is
actually probably closer to a draw then
is for a win so what do you think yeah
that's what I was kind of leaning toward
I was glancing over at the woo Rosen
game again it looks like the pawns are
encroaching on Rosen's territory maybe
not ready to promote yet but trying to
get there yeah so it looks like at least
somewhat Rosen's chances have improved a
little bit so let's see what happened
after Queen g7 white took on g7 and
played rook F 2 it looks like corrupt e7
was maybe a bit more precise but white
bedrock f2 and suddenly you know it
seems like Rosen is having a little bit
of chances again so even though white
wins the spawn but it still feels like
you know in the end games rook end games
there's a famous saying all rock end
games are drawn so at least that's the
one thing that can try to save rose and
here that sometimes rook end games have
more drawing tendencies than any other
end games especially I see a lot of a
see a pawns and I remember from my game
against the Wonder Liang in the first
round of the US Championship I ended up
giving up a draw ecwid extra two points
because I had like their own pawns so
this is kind of the thing that roll
isn't gonna be hoping for here and and
here it looks like Ruby 7 was probably
much cleaner and after this g7 and just
win the game rock a8 let's say and
you know something like room t6 but you
know Rachelle played in a more pragmatic
wave 97 and our Bishop takes rook check
King e5 rook takes rook takes rook b6
and I think why should still be probably
winning but of course black will try to
fight till the very end for a draw but I
think it's safe to say that black will
not win this game at this point it's
only white who could play for a win but
should be winning but of course you
never know for sure until until the end
because blacks pieces black will try to
activate the King and although I think
that if Y just pushes the pawn to f5 and
keeps the rock on b6 it should be
winning but we'll see it will convert
this it looks like a gory and kenta's
game is coming down to its final moments
they're about to draw about the draw
yeah so let's see if any any last
chances were missed but it looks like
yeah h4 was the right plan just trading
off for once because normally when we're
down a pawn in an endgame like that you
know the more pawns which trade off the
easier it becomes because once all the
pawns gets exchanged then black can even
give up the bishop for this pawn and
that will be a draw of course so so if
b6 then you would just take and go g3
with the draw so so white try to play
like this but of course this will be
will be a draw
pretty sure why it's the only chances to
try to somehow lure the bishop out of
the diagonal but there's really no way
to do that so this is gonna be a draw
okay and interesting game over here with
Corley and Abraham Ian in Group A our
final group a game that's still going on
I mean does that be
upon have any chances I has very good
chances I mean that's the main source of
blacks counterplay because if there is
no people and obviously whites would be
winning up two points so that's the main
source of blacks counterplay and whether
that will be enough it will depend on
how they play of course but I think
Black has very serious counter play
chances and also keep in mind all his
pieces are very active so and in an
endgame piece activity is extremely
important so let's see if there any
moves I've played it looks like they're
repeating moves it's I would not be
surprised the faction of white goes for
a draw because it seems like you know
the counter plays indeed real and
serious and they can be actually very
easily a greatsword role in this
position because if why it's gonna
continue playing for a win it will be
kind of risky for him because for
example if you go be 392 at some point
Roxy to beat so the pawn will come
quickly and White's pawns are still kind
of far away so while maybe if you play
very carefully y could still be a little
bit better but it you have to play you
know very very accurately to keep even
slightest winning chances here very well
so let's see what other games we have
only three left in total so let's see if
this game was already so let's see what
happened in the rachelle game yeah well
actually the rachelle game this is the
kind of thing that I was thinking about
I was worried about for Rochelle where
you're up to pawns but this could still
be a long technical road ahead now I I
think this kind of endgame might still
be winning but I know that when there
are two a and H pawn these end games
have actually serious strong chances so
like for example I think here maybe
white should try to secure the porn
first but you know in the game King b3
was played and rugby seven but this end
game whether it's winning I'm not a huge
expert on these rockin games but
actually now black has
honorably with a lot of site checks so
actually I'm seriously worried about
whites winning chances here it might
still be winning but even if it is it's
becoming much more difficult and black
is becoming to get is beginning to get
real drawn chances but how how exactly
do you draw this what does the final
position take shape I mean it would be
something like the cold of Ankara
position it's it's something that you
know the Marriott's key covers and his
manuals I think here where Eric should
go king b6 and try to not let the King
get active and then try to do side
checks and usually the rook is good on
the sixth string at some point like even
when white should say pushes the pawns
that say to h6 you know it's so very
often good to have the rook on a
six-string where it keeps control over
this poor but also you know somewhere in
the effort the G files where you can
always give side checks and not let the
White King make any progress so I mean
these kind of end games you know there
are lots of theoretical positions you
know there's lots of theory on them it's
there they're very hard to play but at
the same time I'm just saying that you
know whether it's actually theoretically
a winning or a drawing position from
practical standpoint of view anything
can happen here and you know we would
probably need to check the the table
basis here to see if if the game is
winning or not did they just do they
just shaker did I just see something no
no I don't think I don't think Rochelle
would agree to a draw here obviously but
and this game is gonna obviously be a
draw now the king is front in front of
the pawns so there's nothing left to
play for and Cossack Orly game let's see
what happened okay so Casa did try to
play for a win Oh actually wait a second
King g5 rook here
okay so Casa did decide to play for a
win with Knight g4 so he decided to keep
the game going but now blacks should
probably try b3 and let white Profis
play after b3 so while he's thinking
let's go back and check on Rachelle's
game so they're a couple of moves have
been played King before rook f1 check
here and then a four so white is making
progress but of course his position is
still could could go either way in my
opinion so there are a couple of my
moves made Eric played rukka for check
result that king b5 and if rook f5 then
king a6 would be the idea I assume oh
all right so let's see this is gonna be
a draw so any moments so let's go back
and check this one so b3 rugby eight has
been played and now white black can even
take the pawn on g3 if he wants to and
yeah white can win the pawn on f6 let's
say with here and there then but still
black with this beep one will you know
get a you know series counter play for a
draw and objective with this position is
is a draw I think okay so with the three
games left we expect this game to be a
draw we expect
Gouri and Kenta in Group B to be a draw
and we think Rochelle might win yeah
that game I would say is kind of around
50/50 because it's still kind of at a
point where the difference of one move
can make a huge difference but I'm not a
hundred percent sure about the exact
evaluation that's what I'm saying that
would be good to check on the Lima yeah
the attainable base we might be able to
see the end of all of these games before
we go off the air today which is rarity
with these short form broadcasts if
we're not in like the final days I want
to tell you though that it's not just
one round a day for today and then
Saturday tomorrow and Sunday there are
two rounds a day in the norm Congress
and you can check it out at us chess
champs calm the rounds each day begin at
11 a.m. and 5 p.m. central time and then
on Monday and Tuesday our final two
rounds will have their own days all to
themselves
both starting at 11 a.m. so we won't
have commentary tonight but round three
will be tonight 5 p.m. us chess champs
calm check it out with our friends at
chess 24 okay I hear that tantas game in
Group A is over let's take a look at
what happened against casa corn black
one goes game black one gasps look
taunted with the victory and I told you
back then you know that I wouldn't be
surprised with any result here even
because and here white made a humongous
blunder hits Castle took on h7 instead
of going let's say King g5 and allow the
simple checkmate ensue so very dramatic
ending so this game and I told you you
know and when there's time pressure in
such a game when you know you're
thinking that you're waiting you're
pressing your pressing it's very easy to
kind of you know lose the idea that you
can lose and kind of very easy to
underestimate the danger in such a
position I've seen that happen so many
times so I'm actually I feel very very
bad for Casa especially given that
yesterday he had a good position against
JJ and blundered in one move and then
today this happens so I really feel bad
for for Casa you know he could have
easily had one and a half or two points
by now but now has to start with zero
out of two so I hope that he keeps
playing as fighting and surprising chess
and keeps staying positive but of course
it's a very unpleasant blow for pro Casa
but very very nice win for the TF and
you know hopefully this is the kind of
game that will get her tournament really
going
maybe this is the break she needs to you
know have a great term and get to 2400
right I mean in these events if it's not
the US Women's Championship she seems to
always be at in one of the lower seeds
if not the lowest seed so you got to
feel good for tatev here one of st.
Louis's longest known and favorite
players against cancer Corley even
though it was a one move slip off what a
pretty slip-up at one yeah yeah that was
that was incredible but that just goes
to show that nerves play a big part
tiredness and everything and anything
can always happen in these games you
know and because humans are humans for a
reason so let's check back on this game
so here of course this this is about to
be a draw because this is a basic King
and pawn endgame draw so I expect they
just play a couple of my moves that will
reach the stalemate and then we'll see
this game and in the draw and the game
over shell against the Eric Rosen let's
see how Rachelle was trying to win this
so she went rogue age five trying to
control the side checks with look at
five but now look f1 a 5 and a 5 is
seems like a shaky move because now this
King doesn't have as much shelter so I'm
not really sure about a 5 maybe your
cage 7 H forward was good like let's say
we could do this and let's say we do
this you know maybe at some point I
think white should focus at some point
white should try to probably sacrifice
this pawn
well not like this because of mate but
you know sacrifice the spawn maybe
because if you go greedy and windows
poor then you can try to Cafe truká 5
you know and then the king can come and
over so something like this at some
point you need to sacrifice one of the
points to be able to win the game
so Rochelle played here king b5 King b7
Rock h5 rook of 105 c1 h7 King v8 ace
six yeah maybe King bees
if King bee six from b1 King a six rook
c1 rakesh six maybe that was but again
this is a very hard endgame to place so
a six was played and then that let's who
this and Roque one yes so I'm still not
sure whether white is winning or not but
I guess we'll see and this game of fish
landed in a draw so now we're only left
with the game over sell very well
whenever we have since we have all the
games in our top division finished
whenever we have those standings ready
for you we will get to them but yeah
with one game left oh okay let's take a
look at our results for our Grandmaster
norm section all the games are finished
here's what happened today tattoo of
Abraham Ian that big win for her last
second slip up by Casa Corley and the
end game allows for a beautiful
checkmate Congrats to her Brandon
Jacobson the Jacobson brothers man what
a great day for them he was a part of
that his victory over Bryan Escalante
right before we went on the air and our
key matchup joel bonala with his victory
over andrew hong got to talk to us in
the studio awesome day for him Boris
tabbouleh AK morant Ali Morandi and wing
they drew their games so we will have
standings for you a little bit later yea
and breaking news here I'm sure Rachelle
was winning here with Ruby 7 check and
then if King a 8 then you can play h4
once again trying to sacrifice the sport
now if black does not take the pawn and
place a move like this then route before
and the king will just come over while
the black King will be cut off
and the white will be winning so black
would probably take the porn but then
after Rugby six actually it looks like
it's still winning because what can
black do you cannot take the trade the
rooks because that will be losing
because you cannot catch the pawn if you
go okay for here in Ruka work here then
rugby five same ideas before you know
you go king over and then you just
promote the pawn and if you go okay five
then rugby 500k six and let's say
something like King D seven check King
e6 and eventually again the King comes
over this King is cut off and this is
winning if black would try after rugby
seven King c8n King b6 should be winning
because after this if black ties down to
the pawn then rock age 7 and then the
pawn will just so let's say black waits
here here here and eventually in the
position like this this is a winning
position because here you're able to
just go to b8 and then just win the
point win the rook so Rochelle was
winning here for sure after up e7
instead she played a7 which i think is a
huge blunder it probably ready blows the
win and then well at least she should
try rock h8 king takes and then H for
which still might be winning but maybe
it's not anymore because after let's say
or okay for this is the position I was
going to talk about a little bit state
called the Bankura position King goes
somewhere and then rook f6 no not not
work of six here okay five and basically
after this Lucas six and this is called
the Vancouver position which you can
read about in a lot of end game manuals
where if white ever goes here then after
this is just a dead draw so why does
force to keep the pawn on h6 but if you
go here you can just go here let's go
ahead and look at the live board
actually this is kind of a funny issue I
think there's an invincible rook on them
yeah that's exactly yeah that's what I
was gonna say yes
so after this h4 to go back here yeah
well H
was you know very bad move because after
h4 clearly you know it's gonna be an
invincible group because there's a
stalemate idea and now it's really just
a draw right away whereas at least if
she would have played rogue h8 black
would still have to know that when kuru
position and still would have to prove
the draw and mean and this could still
be going either way but after this now
it's definitely uh completely dead draw
and feel bad for Rafael but I guess you
know that's part of the learning process
she's the youngest participant the
youngest player in the tournament and
you know sometimes you have to have
these painful things happen to really
learn unfortunately in chess I mean it
happened to me against the wonder where
I didn't win a winning rogue endgame and
that kind of set up about tournament for
me later on let's hope that this doesn't
happen to her shell let's hope she'll be
able to recover off of this miss and
continue playing great chess
let's take a look at the results after
two rounds been played in our I am norm
division so we had Aaron Jacobsen over
Keaton Kyra Luis Torres defeating Aaron
grab in ski before we took to air Peter
G inaros beats Ezra chambers and then
Shankar and chiku Dante have drawn and
Rochelle Wu and Eric rose and drew man
Rochelle came what looked to be pretty
close to drawing blood there but
couldn't get the job done and Rosen
ended up with the mythical immortal rook
take me please take me please
and it's inevitable the game is drawn
that was kind of pretty and so now after
two rounds we know that gory Shakur and
Aaron Jacobsen are in the lead with one
and a half out of two in our IM division
and joel bonala stands tall the only
player in either field with two for two
in the grand master norm section what a
year takes on the day before we sign off
Alex oh yeah was again a very exciting
ground very fighting games pretty much
for the most part and
yeah it just goes to show chest as a
fight it's not about who is
theoretically better it's about who has
the best nerves who has the best
physical fitness who can play the right
moves at the right time and you know who
has you know very good fighting spirit
no Ezra Eric showed here you have to
always fight till then you have to look
for chances in the end as Joel showed us
you can make a mistake losing two
tempies and make a very unpleasant
blunder but still come back very strong
after that and keep a positive mindset
so what matters is how good are your
mindset is throughout the tournament
throughout the game and if you have the
right mindset you will reach your goals
and then that's ultimately what the most
important thing is very well said
remember everybody tonight 5 p.m.
Central time we will have round three at
us chest champs calm check that out the
2019 st. Louis norm Congress will be on
the air again with you tomorrow at 2
o'clock Central Time
I'll be out but we have the one and only
Caleb Denby co-hosting the show along
with Grandmaster Alexander Linderman so
this show was produced by the world's
greatest production B team Danny Machuca
was your technical director Isaac's
rants graphics and audio and Eric Mosel
is the show designer I want to thank
Tammy Hyde for keeping the stream up and
running today and until tomorrow he's
Grandmaster Alex Linderman my name is
Ben Simon we say so long from the
show-me-state
[Music]
you
[Music]
you